the Marcy projects here in Brooklyn New
York why are we here to buy wheat not
this time bill no everyone knows we're
here for one reason and one reason only
we're here for the 8th annual world
series of dice that's right Rob some of
the greatest players from around the
world have gathered here to compete for
the grand prize one another's money and
bragging rights for the whole year
let's meet them these kings of Click
Clack from Kansas City Missouri
legendary shooter grits and gravy grits
and gravy Kansas City Missouri flying in
from the far east is Fiat Hugh one of
the premier dice cutters in the eastern
hemisphere
he has played dice in some of the gully
ax stuff games yeah you funny job rectus
drops a cop gravy and that's Leonard
Washington you know they say Papa didn't
take no mess well neither does Leonard
run a little Washington
well from the town called none get got
damn 50 plate the Dodger pitcher and
finally from these very projects local
legend ashy Larry
[Music]
well there's your man Marcy projects
Marcy's on what okay
that's first world
they made it dried and clean - Kent are
you drinking let's go
I stole this money I'm a good person she
think I'm out emptying the trash which
leaders in chapstick and a set of trout
just like that ashy Larry is a lemonade
she is gonna him up you say okay
grits and gravy is up next now grits is
most known for once rollin 77 sevens in
a row at a casino in Las Vegas making
him a millionaire in the process well
you know Rob earlier today we asked him
what he did with the money
let's take a look about my mama car I
spent the rest on PCP okay simple enough
I don't like the style loves his mother
loves PCP
grits and gravy is ready to roll let's
see how he does come on pudding put up
or shut up double up you take everybody
money sim
sure what y'all know about seven pain me
well you're the gun damn girl put it
down there put it down then the spread
mrs. Brown yeah go home oh you know what
I'm tired ain't got all day I got babies
kissing bitches to catch Oh all in ICU
[Music]
and Leonard laying it on thick an
incredible stare down between Leonard
and grits
look flaring nostrils makes me want to
throw up
[Applause]
rich is eliminated and when I leave come
together like butchy and it comes down
to these two men Leonard Washington and
yuck you almost on cue the game gets
wrong local thug Rodney quills Dinkins
breaking into the Marcy projects hallway
here and telling us all to get
butt-naked
you know bill dice games get robbed it
happens all the time they very rarely
come to a reasonable end TV is no
different what you waiting for cool
breeze dude book your bed now get it off
son first of all you better check your
tone anyway I don't think you know
you're talking to a little Washington
I'll get one nigga from nobody
you want this roll nigga you're going to
shoot me
okay
Hey
and takes a slug through the leg but I
say some problem noticed he's shot a
below the waist so it's not attempted
murder that was very
[Applause]
here comes dumbass I'm gonna trade well
Rob I got a mint I saw this robbery
coming from a mile away which is why I
put my car keys up my ass quick thank
them get their clothes off okay okay
okay so on behalf of bill burr and
quills
I'm Robert Petkov sir did their ring
walk me sorry honey
so long from the Marcy projects and the
world series of dice hopefully next year
we'll be able to get all the way through
it but probably not shut the up man
put the chairs in a box
[Music]
[Applause]